Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David P. Here
is Eric from Massachusetts. We're getting away
from the Eric from stuff very soon. Don't worry.
But he's calling back again with more. I don't
even know what he's talking about. Listen to this.
Speaker 5: And David, it's Derek
from Mass A, I went to the doctor
today and got you won't understand any of
this, but it's called a Titers Test CPRS
and it looks like I do have natural immunity. So
explain to me now why I you a vaccine when I have
natural immunity that does exist. I'm willing
to go on your show, show you the paperwork,
and then have you tell me why I need a
vaccine. But I'm already immune. I mean.
What? I just don't. I thought, gee, I
thought you cared about people. That
was what I thought originally. I'm doing my best
not to jump in, so I really can't. You seem like
a guy on the level and all this just a little
misinformed and just about anybody. Do you still
care about the money again, from the vaccine? And
Alex Jones had a list and you were on it. One of
them made to top. I think they were given up to
50 grand. I mean, do you think you're forward?
Speaker 1: All right. So listen, there is no
evidence anybody has paid me to promote vaccines.
I don't even know why anyone would need to pay
me. I just look at data and I don't promote I
just report what's out there. We've dealt with
this before. Natural immunity is not as strong as
vaccinated immunity and the strongest possible
immunity is vaccinated. Plus recovered from covid.
That's the strongest. So the continued you know,
this is one voicemail. There are dozens of people
who leave me voicemails like this and who
send me emails with the same type of idea.
This is its own virus that is spreading. It's sad
more than anything. But fortunately, you know,
Eric from Mass is in a state of mostly vaccinated
people, and that's a good thing for him to
even if he refuses to get the vaccine, Joe
Manchin might single handedly upend the child tax
credit. We're going to talk about it on today's
bonus show. There is a Pfizer pill in testing
to prevent covid-19. We will talk about that.
And John Hinckley, who shot President Reagan,
has won unconditional release. We will talk
about the details and the back story and
the decision that's been made all on today's
Bonas show. Get instant access to immediate.